NEWS NIGHT.
WE ARE ALSO FOLLOWING SOME
ELECTION NEWS AS WE BEGIN
WITH OUR BREAKING NEWS
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
NEWS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
VERMONT ALONG WITH ONGOING
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATIONS
NUMBERS TO GIVE YOU TONIGHT
AND MUCH MORE.
OMAROSA.
FOR NOW THE FOURTH DAY
ACROSS ALL PLATFORMS, YOUR
DESTROY TRUMP MEDIA
HIGHLIGHTING WHAT IS THE
SALACIOUS CLAIMS, UNTRUE
ACCUSATIONS, SECRET
RECORDINGS FROM, YES,
OMAROSA, A PERSON FIRED
THREE TIMES FROM A REALITY
SHOW AND BY THE WAY ONCE
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE WHERE
SHE WAS HIRED BY DONALD
TRUMP.
ACCORDING TO GENERAL KELLY,
BECAUSE OF SERIOUS
CREDIBILITY AND CHARACTER
ISSUES.
THAT'S NOT BROUGHT UP VERY
PEDDLERS SEVEN DAYS A WEEK,
MINUTE, HOUR BY HOUR.
HOUR 72 PLUS WHAT CAN ONLY
BE DESCRIBED AS THE OMAROSA
REALITY SHOW.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> BREAKING NEWS IN OUR
POLITICS LEAD IN THE UGLY
WAR OF WORDS BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND OMAROSA
MANIGAULT NEWMAN.
>> OMAROSA MANIGAULT NEWMAN.
OMAROSA.
>> OMAROSA.
>> GUYS, BUCKLE UP, HERE IS
JUST PART OF MY INTERVIEW
WITH OMAROSA MANIGAULT
NEWMAN.
>> OMAROSA MANIGAULT NEWMAN.
OMAROSA.
>> OMAROSA.
CIRCLE OF THE CAMPAIGN.
>> Sean: I HAVE TO ADMIT
IT'S A LITTLE HUMOROUS THIS
OBSESSIVE ANTI-TRUMP
IN FACT, THIS ECHO CHAMBER
IT NEVER STOPS IT JUST MOVES
CRISIS TO CRISIS, SECOND BY
SECOND.
MINUTE BY MINUTE.
HOUR BY HOUR.
DAVE BY DAY.
24/7, 365.
WE HAVE GOT THE EVIDENCE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> NOW THEY WILL CERTAINLY
>> THE STORMY SAG DA.
>> STORMY DANIELS.
>> STORMY DANELS LAWYER.
>> WE HAVEN'T HEARD FROM HIM
ABOUT THE STORMY DANIELS
AFFAIR.
>> ADULT FILM STAR BREAKING
HER SILENCE ABOUT HER AFFAIR
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> TALKING ABOUT THE MOST
SERIOUS LEGAL ALLEGATIONS.
>> I AM A PROUD [BLEEP]
>> NO.
WE ARE NOT ALL CREATED
EQUAL.
AT LEAST IF YOU ARE NOT BORN
IN AS THE PRESIDENT PUT IT A
OF.
[BLEEP] NOT HOLE COUNTRIES.
>> IS THERE A DIFFERENCE IF
THE PRESIDENT SAID [BLEEP]
>> DO YOU THINK THESE
COUNTRIES ARE HOLES?
>> DONALD TRUMP HAS TURNED
THE OLE OFFICE INTO A
[BLEEP]
>> THIS IS A PRESIDENT
COMMENTS YESTERDAY.
>> Sean: TODAY NO DIFFERENT.
PRESS SECRETARY SARAH
HUCKABEE SANDERS RESPONDING
TO ALL OF THIS A PRETTY
POWERFUL REBUTTAL.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> UNFORTUNATELY, THE
INDIVIDUALS IN THIS ROOM
CONTINUE TO CREATE A LARGE
PLATFORM FOR SOMEBODY THEY
KNOW NOT TO HAVE A LOT OF
CREDIBILITY FOR SOMEONE THEY
FRANKLY REFUSED TO GIVE A
PLATFORM TO WHEN THEY WORKED
HERE AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
NEGATIVELY ATTACK THIS
TEAR THIS ENTIRE PLACE DOWN
THAT SHE RECEIVED THE TYPE
OF PLATFORM AND ROLLOUT THAT
I THINK IT WOULD BE GREAT IF
EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN THIS
ROOM AND EVERY SINGLE PERSON
IN THE ADMINISTRATION NEVER
HAD TO TALK ABOUT THIS AGAIN
REAL THINGS THAT NOT MATTER
JUST TO PEOPLE IN THIS
BUILDING BUT CERTAINLY ALL
AMERICANS,
AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANICS, AND EVERYBODY IN
BETWEEN.
CERTAINLY DO FOR OUR
COUNTRY.
>> Sean: TONIGHT, OUR
FRIENDS AT THE MEDIA
RESEARCH CENTER ARE BACKING
UP WHAT YOU JUST HEARD FROM
SARAH HUCKABEE
SARAH SUCKABEE
SARAH SANKABEE
SARAH SANDEBEE
SARAH SANDERSE
SARAH SANDERS.
TODAY CBS, NBC, THEY
THAN THEY DID COVERING THE
FIRING OF FBI AGENT PETER
REPORTING FOR SALACIOUS
RUMORS OVER WHAT IS SERIOUS
NEWS ABOUT WHAT IS A
CORRUPT, HIGH RANKING FBI
OFFICIAL FIRED BECAUSE OF
HIS MASSIVE BIAS AND
CORRUPTION AT THE HEART OF
EVERYTHING FROM HILLARY TO
GENERAL FLYNN TO THE
BEGINNING OF THE
RUSSIA-TRUMP HOAX AND TODAY
AS HE OFTEN DOES, THE
PRESIDENT BYPASSED THE
PARTISAN PRESS IN THE
COUNTRY.
HE TOOK HIS MESSAGE RIGHT TO
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HE TWEETED OUT, QUOTE:
FIRED FBI AGENT PETER STRZOK
IS A FRAUD, AS IS THE RIGGED
INVESTIGATION THAT HE
STARTED.
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION OR
DEMOCRATS, KNOW IT.
THE ONLY COLLUSION AND
DNC.
AND TONIGHT, A NEW REPORT IS
NOW BOLSTERING THE
PRESIDENT'S CLAIM.
REAL CLEAR INVESTIGATION.
THEY ARE SHOWS SERIOUS
QUESTIONS NOW BEING RAISED
ABOUT FUSION GPS FOUNDER
GLENN SIMPSON AND THE
SHADOWY RUSSIAN FIGURES WHO
ATTENDED THE NOW INFAMOUS
2016 TRUMP TOWER MEETING.
BY THE WAY, ROBERT MUELLER
IF YOU ARE LOOKING FOR
POTENTIAL RUSSIA COLLUSION
WE HAVE GOT MORE.
DIG UP WHAT RUSSIAN DIRT ON
THEN CANDIDATE DONALD TRUMP.
TONIGHT THERE ARE NEW
THEAFERLS THE RUSSIAN LAWYER
WHO ATTENDED THAT MEETING.
THAT EVERYONE HAS BEEN
TALKING ABOUT.
SHE UTILIZED SIMPSON'S
SERVICES TO LOBBY AGAINST
RUSSIAN SANCTIONS.
THIS PLOT JUST KEEPS
THINKING AND ACCORDING TO
TESTIMONY SHE HAD DINNER
WITH SIMPSON BOTH BEFORE AND
AFTER THE TRUMP TOWER
MEETING.
SOUNDS LIKE A SET-UP TO ME.
AND BECAUSE SIMPSON'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH THAT
KREMLIN TIED LAWYER, CHICAGO
FINANCIER NAMED WILLIAM
BROWDER WAS, QUOT:
BROWDER WAS, QUOTE SO
CONCERNED ABOUT FUSION'S
G.P.S. WORK ON BEHALF OF
G.P.S. WAS WORKING ON BEHALF
THE DNC HILLARY CLINTON AND
ALSO RUSSIAN-BACKED
INTERESTS.
THAT'S RIGHT.
IT'S ALL LITERALLY
IT SOUNDS.
BUT, WHERE IS THE HYSTERIA
FROM THE MEDIA?
LYING TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WITH PHONY RUSSIAN
INFORMATION THAT IS PAID FOR
BY THE OPPOSITION PARTY
CANDIDATE.
AND THEN USED FOR A FISA
WARRANT.
WHERE IS THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION?
OH, IT'S NOT REALLY AN
INVESTIGATION INTO COLLUSION
NOW, IS IT?
IT'S A PARTISAN WITCH-HUNT
AMERICAN PEOPLE, HAVE SEEN
THROUGH THIS AND HAVE HAD
ENOUGH.
EVEN FAKE NEWS CNN HAS A
POLL THAT SHOWS, THAT'S
RIGHT, TWO THIRDS OF YOU,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, ARE NOW
CALLING FOR ROBERT MUELLER
TO WRAP THIS GARBAGE UP.
AND THIS DOCUMENTS
AND THIS COCUMENTS
AND THIS COMUMENTS
AND THIS COMESENTS
AND THIS COMES ATS
AND THIS COMES ASS
AND THIS COMES AS THE TRIAL
OF THE CENTURY MAY BE COMING
TO AN END.
AFTER 11 DAYS THE DEFENSE
RESTED IN THE BANK AND TAX
FRAUD CASE OF PAUL MANAFORT
FROM 2005.
THEY DIDN'T BOTHER CALLING A
SINGLE WITNESS.
MANAFORT'S LEGAL TIME
APPARENTLY BELIEVES THAT THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL DID NOT MEET
THEIR BURDEN.
THE BURDEN OF PROOF.
AND THEY MAY BE RIGHT.
ACCORDING TO ANALYSIS FROM A
NORTHERN VIRGINIA CRIMINAL
DEFENSE ATTORNEY, TEAM
MUELLER WAS NOT READY FOR
PRIME TIME IN JUDGE ELLIS'
COURTROOM.
QUOTE:  NO MATTER HOW STRONG
THEIR EVIDENCE.
HOW RIGHTEOUS THEIR CAUSE,
HOW IMPRESSIVE THEIR RESUMES
MAY BE AND ACTUALLY ARE,
THEY SIMPLY HAVE NOT DONE A
VERY GOOD JOB.
CLEARLY MUELLER WAS TRYING
TO TURN THE SCREWS ON
MANAFORT AS JUDGE ELLIS TOLD
US, HE NEVER WANTED TO GO TO
TRIAL.
HE JUST WANTED MANAFORT TO
SING OR TO COMPOSE SO THAT
MUELLER COULD GIVE UP
SOMETHING OR MAKE UP
SOMETHING, ANYTHING, TO THEN
PROSECUTE OR IMPEACH DONALD
TRUMP.
AND DESPITE TEAM MUELLER'S
POOR PERFORMANCE IN COURT.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF FEDERAL
CASE RESULT IN A GUILTY
VERDICT, OVER 90%.
THIS CASE, FOR THE RECORD,
AND MANE WE'LL GET EVEN AS
EARLY AS THURSDAY OF THIS
WEEK, A VERDICT.
DO WITH DONALD TRUMP.
NOTHING TO DO WITH RUSSIA,
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
ELECTION AT ALL.
ROD ROSENSTEIN'S MANDATE
AND MEANWHILE, WHAT DO WE
HAVE?
HILLARY CLINTON COMMITTING
MULTIPLE, SERIOUS FELONIES,
CRIMES?
MISHANDLING TOP SECRET
INFORMATION?
SHE OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE WHEN
WATCHED HER HARD DRIVES WITH
BLEACH BIT, WATCHED THEM
AWAY SO THEY COULD NEVER BE
FOUND AGAIN.
BROKE UP HER DEVICES WITH
HAMMERS.
FIXED AND RIG AN
INVESTIGATION WITH STEELE'S
DIRTY DOSSIER.
REMEMBER, THAT WAS FULL OF
RUSSIAN LIES AND PEDALED TO
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO
MISINFORM YOU, TO STEAL AN
ELECTION.
THAT'S CALLED PROPAGANDA.
MISINFORMATION.
AND THAT INFORMATION WAS
THEN PRESENTED TO FOUR
EVIDENCE.
NOBODY HAD EVER LITERALLY
VERIFIED ANY OF IT,
CORROBORATED ANY OF IT.
NOBODY HAS BEEN INDICTED,
INVESTIGATED BY TEAM MUELLER
REGARDING CLINTON'S DIRTY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
THIS IS A DISGRACE TO
AMERICA'S SYSTEM OF JUSTICE.
IT IS A CLEAR AND DANGER --
CLEAR AND PRESENT DANGER TO
OUR CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, MANAFORT IS
FOUND GUILTY?
STORMY, STORMY, STORMY.
BLANK HOLE, BLANK HOLE,
BLANK HOLE, RUSSIA, RUSSIA,
RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
FORCED TO CALL THEM OUT FOR
THEIR SHAMELESS, PRICELESS
PEDDLING.
YES, JOURNALISM IN AMERICA
IS DEAD.
BUT THE REAL FEAR OUGHT TO
BE WHETHER OR NOT WE HAVE A
JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT APPLIES
EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW,
EQUAL APPLICATION OF OUR
LAWS.
THIS IS REALLY ABOUT RUSSIA,
WHY ARE WE DEALING WITH A
2005 TAX CASE NOT RELATED TO
THE CAMPAIGN OR RUSSIA OR
THE DIRTY DOSSIER WITH
RUSSIAN LIES THAT ABOUT
PEDDLED TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE?
WHY AREN'T WE INVESTIGATING
FISA COURT JUDGES THAT WERE
ABSOLUTELY, A FRAUD WAS PER
WHAT ABOUT ADAM SCHIFF?
SHIFT J SCHIFF AND HE IS
TALKING TO RUSSIANS ON THE
PHONE.
GPS, GLENN SIMPSON MEETING
BEFORE AND AFTER WITH THE
CLIENT THAT MET WITH DON JR.
AND COMPANY AT TRUMP TOWER
AND ALSO, RUSSIA IS A CLIENT
OF HIS ALSO?